[Music]
all right hello
you are listening to the pill pod i'm
here with
chris who you might have heard from the
previous vitalism episode
and today we're going to do a very broad
introduction
to de luz and the reason for that is
later in the week we are going to be
interviewing ian
buchanan who is one of the foremost
uh de lis scholars in the
english-speaking world at least but
probably the world in general you think
he's probably he's top five for sure you
think
i i would think so for sure at least in
dulles studies and
that whole yes he's the editor
and founder of the de lis and guitari
studies
journal so um he has that to his name
but because we don't know specifically
how that conversation
is going to go and delivers can be very
daunting if you kind of don't know
what's going on
um so i wanted to do this with eucharist
this uh
less interview style but more let's talk
about the significance of the liz and
why
it matters for sure so
i am not a liz scholar um whereas chris
you are
or was it's not your area now but you
have
i like that i like i like to say that
i'm a recovering delizian
and the distinct what we're
distinguishing here is
you can read de las but to actually be a
delish scholar
means that you're also reading everybody
else who reads delos
so i've read a fair share of de luz but
i don't know all the specific debates
that are going on in academia and all
that stuff
so hopefully for the most part we can
stay away from that
because this is more of an episode of if
you open up a deluse book
it's going to sound probably pretty
jarring
maybe pretty alienating you're not going
to know what's going on so
the idea here is to set the stage for
that interview that we're going to have
so that you know at least where we're
coming from and a little bit of what
dela's
slash guitari in some cases is about
i think that's very well said so there's
yeah i was going to do a whole
introductory video on deliz but
i don't really like doing introductory
videos because it kind of stops you from
dealing with concepts so i think this is
a better medium for explaining but
we can just tell we can just tell our we
can just tell our viewers that you know
delis was born in 1925 in france and
died in 1995
of suicide jumping from his uh uh window
um he was dying of lung cancer he had a
spring
put into his lung at the age of 45. um
and he took his own life because he felt
that
we as humans need to own our own death
and that he felt that the cancer that
was killing him was
was taking more out of his own autonomy
so he took his own life
yeah he didn't want to die in a hospital
bed which is actually pretty reflective
of his philosophical project
so to focus on his philosophical project
which is
vast i have broken down
this chris you can push back on any of
these categories if you wish but
just for the sake of clarity i think the
best way to deal with this is to talk
about
four different delusions okay
do you want to hear them sure sure okay
i would love to hear them uh you can
push back but it basically divides his
books
into a few different categories so first
and probably the most well-known
is the de luz who writes with gatari so
dng
de luz these are the books from
capitalism and schizophrenia
including thousand plateaus anti-oedipus
later on what is philosophy his book on
kafka
the towards a minor literature the minor
literature book nomedology and i know
i'm just
saying a bunch of words but we're
dividing up his books into
his own sections then we have deliz
the intellectual historian many of which
he wrote these books by himself for the
most part
but he writes on his first book was on
hume
um he wrote on nietzsche he wrote on
spinoza he wrote on leibniz
and this is when de luz is dealing very
closely with these
texts and interpreting them
very much for his own ends in a way
he's not trying to be you know here's
here's the story of this philosopher's
life he's more
interpreting oh we could take this
concept and develop it and he calls them
conceptual personae
that's it that's that's a good way to
that's a good way to get into him yeah
and i think these are these are kind of
your favorite books right
yes um i like his monographs on
philosophers and i also like
how if you're interested in spinoza or
nietzsche or bergson or kant or
any one of them they're really good to
pick up um
and if you just jump into what is
philosophy which he wrote with gutari
he reflects on these monographs right
like when he starts talking about
concepts so it's good
if you pick up one of his books let's
say the spinoza book or the hume book
and then jump into the what is
philosophy book he reflects on these and
reflects on why these thinkers matter to
his
new canon as he calls them and actually
if you've never read de las
anything by deliz before i think what is
philosophy
is actually a pretty good place to start
because he wrote it at the
near the end of his life i think it was
his
one of his last books yeah and he kind
of reflects on what he was doing
the whole rest of the time yeah he says
he says he could only write one of these
books
at in old age he he tries to think of
kant
writing the last book the critique of
judgment which is so completely
different than the other books
but he says there's something about this
old age that makes him get to this kind
of reflecting moment
on his entire uvra or body of works
and it's not a difficult book so it
might be a good place to start if you
think oh this is
extremely interesting but uh
we'll see well it depends on the reader
i don't that's just my opinion
um then okay so we have the dng dillas
then we have the intellectual historian
monograph de las
and then de la is the metaphysician and
this is
what difference in repetition is called
his opus
because it's his most uh personal
intervention into the history of
philosophy when he's saying i'm going to
go in a whole new
direction from philosophy since plato
right right um it's it's his
it was his dissertation thesis um
it also starts off his his work
it puts him in line with foucault as
well um
and and it focuses on the conception of
difference
which he looks through the entire
history of philosophy
and targets three main people um
freud um hegel and
leibniz um and he and he really goes
into these three
and we'll talk about that later and yeah
you mentioned foucault so he was pretty
tight with foucault
i guess in his 70s and then they had a
little bit of a philosophy cat fight
which philosophers are prone to do
i mean tongue-in-cheek i define all of
19th
century philosophy as kantians and
hegelians calling each other idiots and
you know
insulting each other that's a pretty
actually if you look at any of ficta's
letters to anybody
that's a perfect definition he wrote
scathing scathing
comments to hegel and shelling et cetera
et cetera
and they're quite personal so we think
of these people as high-minded
intellectuals dealing with metaphysics
and then they're just
calling each other [ __ ] basically the
the proto-twitter
um and then finally there's the ascii
aesthete
de las where he writes on film
and he writes on art and kind of
cultural products
as aesthetics and what's interesting
though is
if you want to do something like film
studies or like critical art studies
don't read these because he only looks
at movies and uh
art so that he can put his own ideas and
say that this is what was happening all
along
he certainly doesn't like the he doesn't
like the classical age or the
renaissance age of art
for sure he does not like that at all
and he's also not aesthetically critical
he's just saying
oh if you read this my way then here's
all the stuff you can get out of it
so time image so he has two books on
cinema
and uh logic of uh sensibility
the logic of sensation a sensation sorry
where he writes on
art and things like that so to recap we
have four
delizzes dng de lis
intellectual historian de las
metaphysician de las
and aesthete de las and whichever book
you're looking at
is going to define the writing style
that you're going to be looking at so uh
i think probably a lot of delizians
would hate that i'm breaking it down
that way because they'll
say no this is a combined philosophical
project i'm pretty sure most illusions
hate each other anyways so it doesn't
matter
they're continuing the tradition of
philosophy philosophical cat fights
anyway that's that's the map that i have
in my head when i'm opening up
this text or this text or this text
that's the personal map that i use
whether or not it's true or
helpful or useful that remains totally
up to you
so how do you want to start this chris
we we could deal with a few
different things but uh do you have any
ideas
um okay so
pretty much um when dillas wrote his
dissertation
he had written on difference of
repetition he'd written his books on
hume and spinoza
um and he felt um that he was at kind of
a roadblock
because he'd written on so many con so
many concepts
and he was introduced actually to um
uh guitaree um and apparently they spent
the entire night talking
about concepts and and they had a really
really good
relationship right off the bat by the
way all of this information is from
francois dossier's text
intersecting live so and i want to
interject there
just to say what's what's he called
himself
or he he was commenting on his own work
and i think he called himself like a
bureaucrat
or an academic bureaucrat or something
disparaging like that
but meeting with meeting up with qatari
and becoming friends
uh changed the way that he wrote
and presumably the way that he thought
obviously we can't
decide on that either way but he he
re he re-envisioned philosophy from
having met guitar and just a little bit
of background
on ghitary he was
a he was like a protesting academic he
was like
in the streets uh communist
and he studied psychoanalysis
under lacan lacan was his analyst
and he kind of severed ties a little bit
because he thought likanian philosophy
or the lacan school of psychoanalysis
was a little bit too cultish for him
yeah he said this in an interview that i
read uh
two weeks ago interestingly when they
met um
de los gave uh quattari his text the
logic of sense
which has a lot of psychoanalysis in it
and the critiques there were of freud
so apparently during this era lacan had
asked de lewis to to sit in one of his
lectures
during the logic of sense time um
roughly the critique of freud
so this is an interesting period of um
you know intellectual richness between
two thinkers you know
thinking out politics how how these
concepts can
go out in the street how they can be
taken to the street actually so that was
a good point that you brought up about
his
uh gotari's activism and the
anti-oedipus book which is the first
book they wrote together
as far as i know right right yep let's
just assume
let's just assume that i'm right about
that um it was very
it was very much dealing with the
problems raised
in psychoanalysis uh more freudian
psychoanalysis
than than the khan but it was arguing
for a
a different sort of model yes
yes so it was definitely it was against
the kind of
you know the the edible the edible
complex sorry
um the the kind of triangulation of the
mother
father etc signifier they were really
trying to target this and they were
looking at different organizations
such as the state such as religion the
religious orders
as well as the media et cetera and this
brings up a
central tenet that's going to define
delizi's entire trajectory and his whole
philosophical project which is
increasingly anti-establishment
in certain ways because you said this
word the state and the state is very
much
a concern to them in the same way that
it's a concern to
to foucault actually but
instead of having this state as an
ultimate position
they're kind of trick they call it
machines right they try to figure out
all the different machines
that make up the state instead of
positing an er
concept or a totalizing concept like
power
right and this is one of the if
if you know anything about phil cole you
probably know the word power
but what's very different from people
who interpret foucault and write about
foucault
is they presume that power
is just this like miasma or this uh
cloud that just exists everywhere in
society
whereas if you actually read foucault
the way he
does his text in terms of madness or in
terms of
hospitals or in prisons it always starts
from
the details it's uh what would you call
it it's uh
inductive reasoning and he says okay
here's how a prison works now let's
establish
power and the conclusion of the book is
power
right and so quattari and de las maybe
extend that concept of power
and look at how the flow of power and
they bring up these concepts of
of suppleness or or molecular which is
the free-flowing
uh concept of power and the molecule
sorry
the molar which is the uh constrictive
and segmented segmenting and the
enclosed kind of aspect of power that
the contraction of power
the um the seducing of power and then
there'd be like the supple
mole molecular which is the kind of free
flowing which
is in a good way it opens up structures
but they also limit
i'm going to interrupt you here because
this is the
big problem that people have with read
delusion guitar is it gets
very jargony and this is just meant to
be an introduction
so right i'm sorry yeah no don't be
sorry this is
the way delisians always talk and i'm
meant to be
the the voice of the people here
right the vox populum
but if we talk about power we have
hierarchies right and
everyone can see hierarchies wherever
you look if you look into
schools if you look into government
if you look into you know police versus
civilian
there's always hierarchies of power
and delusion gatari investigate this a
little bit more carefully but they also
look at the history of philosophy in
terms of
hierarchy so even going back to plato
he makes distinguish or a distinction
between
appearance and real and the real
is this the stable background to all
appearances
appearances are temporal they're not
trustworthy
um and then you get copies like artists
copy appearances which are copies of the
real
so it's this hierarchy where you have an
invisible
background that is the true reality
right
and then everything beyond or everything
that's
lower on the the pole or lower on the
tree we can come back to that lower on
the tree is less
real so the most real is the best
and this is he they attack
representation a lot right so
representation when you say one thing
represents something else then you're
kind of saying that that something
else is better and that the thing that's
copying it
is worse which creates a hierarchy in
thought but they're also dealing with
hierarchies of the state and the family
as you said
yeah i like this idea of the tree um
um because what is a tree a tree is uh
it's vertical it's standing up it has
one way of expressing itself which are
its branches
its branches can go in one direction and
that's it
and this is kind of brilliantly is
leading us into the
the rhizome in a second so if we think
of um
what i was saying before like you know
religious orders the state
god etc etc etc you can see this at
on the hierarchy of the tree right and
so each level of power or each level
from the state onward is a kind of a
branch that is
cutting off your ability to be a free
autonomous individual
so the liz and qatari are trying to
think of
ways to um
what they would say i mean i'm going to
use the jargon but i'll talk about
what it is to look about the way of
overcoating or or trying to make
this tree organism cut completely off
or to to flip it right on its head right
and if we want to go
why that is think of
you have the tree of knowledge which is
a metaphor in western philosophy
that at least philosophers use because
you know makes them look the most
important
but the roots of knowledge are
philosophy
and then once you go up the up the trunk
then you have the trunk which is
i don't know science
so the science is the solid center
of knowledge and then you have the
branches and the branches
are the most easily removed so the least
necessary
and those are like the applied sciences
so when you
when you do chemistry you're not doing
pure science you're doing applied
science
so the whole point here i mean it's a
kind of an inverse hierarchy is to
say what's the most important thing
which is often
you know metaphysics and then as soon as
you start applying stuff
and as soon as you become like and then
the most the top most branches the most
useless branches are
arts right yeah so you have that right
so that this is right out of descartes
so you know the empirical sciences
et cetera et cetera but notice how there
is no room for growth
there is no room for any free creativity
what we have there is what is certain
it's certain that the empirical sciences
give us this it's certain that
um the arts will do this it doesn't
really give any room for
novel creativity and this is where
deloitte steps in and this is why delis
has a different
canon of thinkers because he wants to
hit de la's and qatari want to
investigate the history of philosophy
and of psychoanalysis i guess to see how
they can make these
creative inversions on the history that
has created this kind of tree structure
so um how can they do this
and this is called major philosophy
yeah and major philosophy is their [ __ ]
list
and i'm being reductive here because
they write on major philosophy
and anyone who studies major philosophy
is going to
be is probably going to object to this
but we have major philosophy
and then we have minor philosophy so
major philosophy
is the people you read in an
undergraduate philosophy class
you start with plato you go to aristotle
uh
then for whatever reason skip two
thousand
or fifteen hundred years then you're at
descartes then you have kant then you
have hegel
um and so on so this is major philosophy
and they wanna distance themselves from
that
you know for the most part there's
always exceptions and then they have a
minor philosophy which includes p
uh what you haven't heard of probably in
in most philosophy classes which is
spinoza bergson nietzsche you probably
have but nietzsche's
in this train so they want to have a a
parallel line
of people that were rejecting the norm
they were opposed to the norm in
whatever way sometimes they were
opposed to the norm sometimes they
weren't but delusion guitaree
or at least no mostly delays i think in
this case right
yeah yeah for sure these are his
monographs so delis yeah
dylan gets these small ideas out of
these thinkers and say no they're part
of
the minor philosophy which in his mind
is good it's better than
major philosophy yeah and it's it's as
simple as
someone like lucretius's klinemann or
the the adam swerve he likes this idea
of free-flowing activity
free creation that that that can somehow
be spontaneously
spontaneously erupt he likes this idea a
rupture
um something that's intensive
right um you see a lot of delusion
articles people talk about
intensity what is intensity so from
lucretius
up to spinoza and what he loves about
spinoza is this concept of imminence
he has a very strong imminent kind of
holistic model that he that grasps um
the creative structure of reality
so and i think he calls them orphans but
i'll give you the list
listener just so you can have the list i
wrote it down
as you mentioned lucretius spinoza
leibniz hume nietzsche bergson
those are the main the main list of
minor philosophers whereas
most other people who would call part of
the majority
philosophy view hegel especially i don't
think they have
profound love for hegel deserved or not
because you know what our hegelian
our hegelian friends are going to
message me as soon as they hear this i
know
but that's the greatest he has the
greatest line he says
one of the one of the one of the one of
the most disgusting things that he had
ever
ever seen come into existence was the
dialectic and hegelian philosophy
yeah and you can kind of see the reason
for this is because hegel's dialectic of
history overall
basically explains all of history so
it's totalizing
um and you know what we're not going to
do that on this podcast but we can push
back on that and say no like there's
spontaneity in hegel
there's there's there really is reason
to believe that but just for the sake of
this episode we're going to reduce it to
a binary which says hegel's a bad
philosopher because he doesn't allow for
true spontaneity and true like
resistance
because if history is all one process
then what is resistance for there could
be no resistance so
liz and khatari are very interested in
this concept
of resistance and they give it a very
physical form in terms of
becoming woman becoming animal
becoming minor um the kafka book was
about jews so jews have to write in
german
in germany but they come at it from an
outside
even though they're you know inside
the german geist this is yeah this is
the
this is the beautiful thing about the
kafka book because he brings up the idea
that kafka is a
is a a a prague jew he's from prague
and what he likes about it is one of the
first concepts that de las really
really works out is the stutterer and
what does a stutterer do
a stutterer takes yiddish and applies it
to the major language which is german
and the stutter adds a kind of
intonation to the language
to the word so it it and then
all of a sudden you see the major people
the the
the kind of bourgeois society start
using these minor words which brings out
the minitarian
um politics right and if we want to go
into
let's let's bring in identity politics
here actually because it's
quite a useful application um
for de luz to be a minority
and it doesn't have to be a numerical
minority just like something outside the
dominant discourse
so in north american culture it would be
non-white non
heterosexual and non-male
and especially in terms of like um
transgressive gender identities right in
terms of non-heteronormativity
these things are not something that you
are
because if you are woman black
minor transgender or whatever then
you're going to be caught in the logic
of the state
so this is his notion of becoming minor
which is constantly reinventing that
minority stance and that minority stance
is actually where you get a form of
power from
so i don't know if you can think of
examples i think the the first example
that comes to
my mind is like new york
hip-hop in the in the early 90s
where you get you got all these african
symbols as a part of the hip-hop you
know like
africa bombata but even even the even
the break dancing scene where you when
you see african-american
african-americans
break dancing in the streets you know
kind of taking back the space
right sorry to interrupt you oh i mean
that's a perfect example because you're
not
your identity is not something that you
are it's something that you create
and this philosophy of creativity is
very
important and it just doesn't have to do
with visible or political minorities
either
delusion katari saw themselves as a
minority
a minority language within philosophy so
it's about everyone should be doing this
kind of resistance
to the state and to totalizing
categories
and that looks different for every
person it looks different for artists it
looks different for scientists it looks
different for philosophers it looks
different for
you know visible minorities right and
this is this is what he this is what the
lizard quattari say that creation is
creation is a form of resistance a pure
form of resistance
actually um to create something
in replace of something stagnant or
static
is a is a form of resistance to to read
spinoza instead of kant or to
like someone like uh eric satee and
music over
i don't know britney spears or something
to get into this kind of or wagner oh
we can always [ __ ] on wagner safely
because he's gonna have to sound like
we could just do that for vlogger yes so
when we are talking about hierarchy
where we have our image model of the
tree
which is vertical some parts are above
some parts are more important some parts
are lesser
and this is where they get the concept
of the rhizome from which is one of the
most oft-quoted
concepts and a rhizome
is a plant-like it's like grass or
fungus because a fungus or grass
there's no center right there's there's
not a single place
where everything else comes from there's
no trunk to grass
so when he talks about the rhizome it's
what's the word it's non-hierarchical
but it's flat it's horizontal so there's
not a power structure
where you have one thing that's
important and then everything else is
less important which is you know the
whole platonic thing you have
you have a real world you have the idea
and then you have all the applications
to the idea which are unnecessary
in a rhizome there's no part that's more
necessary to an other
which is why it's non-hierarchical and
this is why this quote or this
concept is so often redeployed it's also
you can see this in animal life as well
too he brings up examples like wolf
wolves the wolf pack is a form of a
rhizome it's an expression of the entire
um the entire collective of all the
wolves
um he likes mice or rats sorry the rat
he loves the idea of
rats um and they're kind of scurrying
around
as a kind of animal rhizome yeah and you
can think of
i don't know ant hills termite colonies
they
they have sort of a center but they're
much less decentralized
than excuse me
they're much less decentralized than
something like a human
state because the state is all about
these
different organs you have the
legislators at the top
you have your government officials at
the top then you have your bureaucrats
and then you have like your classes so
he he even comes against
marx a little bit for considering power
to stately like and then his criticism
he criticizes marx's criticism
of capitalism yeah like my my favorite
example
um from a thousand plateaus is when de
lis talks about a weed and what
what is a weed a wheat is something
that's horizontal
it's fl that moves horizontally
and has an infinite amount of
possibilities
expressions that it can merge into as
opposed to just
growing you know like a telos like a
like a teleology growing into a plant
being just like our structure we said
like the tree just being vertical and
that's it in growing branches
and leaves etc this is a perfect example
right because the hierarchy the state is
the garden and the garden
what makes a garden a garden you plant
things in horizontal rows
you're like envisioning what this garden
is going to look like later you have
your nice plants up here
you have your shade plants in the shade
so it's all organized
in like a grid like pattern to look
good to a certain sort of mind but then
the weed comes in
and the weed disrupts this planned out
representational organization of the
garden that's
perfect thank you yeah and it's funny
too because let's lose let's
use a little bit of jargon here so one
second that's two
two words here so as as pills
as plastic pill said so perfectly you
have this grid like formation of the
garden which is coded
it's a code you put this plant in you
put the seed in in a line
now what does the weed do it over codes
the code
it goes over that distinction it goes
over that structure
yeah you could think of it like an
invasive
a virus even although
viruses cancer i don't know if we wanted
to bring up viruses in times like these
but you know
they overcode the
hierarchical grid-like organization of
things and he
and for deliza sorry this is the goal is
to
be the over-coders be the subversives
and it doesn't mean like you can
overthrow a massive state right like
you're not gonna
overthrow the united states by
protesting in the street
but just the act of protesting in the
street is an important
intensity that you can bring into
politics
right and and it's so funny that we're
going to have ian
buchanan on here um i think it's next
week
because this week also hopefully this
week sorry hopefully
if i can get it done turn around time
but yeah
ian says something brilliant in his
article on the internet he says that if
liz was if de liz was alive the greatest
rhizome that he would see
come into power or come into into
existence would be the internet
you can open up you know the screens
that are popping up the
i mean you you know this more than i do
yeah i think
i think that dream is dead though like
this was the whole cyberpunk
movement in the 90s was like oh we have
a free space
but now even the internet has become inc
like totalized totalized uh
categorized it's extremely hierarchical
so
i want to introduce one term we're not
going to do heavy terms here
but we have the rhizome which is this
sort of free-flowing there's no center
it can pop up anywhere
versus the tree and the word for the
tree hierarchy
is the arborescent so arbor arbor
latin means tree so something that is
arborescent is hierarchicalized
something that is rhizomatic is free and
you could point to the internet
at least in the uh mid 90s as being a
lot more
distributed than it is now and there you
could still seize a
pawn those tendencies maybe but you know
the internet
becomes more and more hierarchicalized
and monopolized
so there's another term we could we
could drop here
that might help make sense and that's
the nomad
because the nomad is
someone without a territory or someone
that can cross
freely between territories and as soon
as we talk about the nomad
then there's a whole bunch of terms that
we can use that if you've ever read the
liz you've probably
read before so territorializing
and deterritorializing um
and i think you could probably say that
for deliz becoming territorialized
it's not like it's bad right but if you
get stuck there and you get
stuck in your ways and you never
try to push against those
limits then you're kind of not living a
real life and you you said this
if you haven't listened to our vitalism
episode yet uh you should
but this is kind of an area where deliz
is considered a vitalist but it can also
be applied to politics
if you stay in your lane and you stay in
your box
that's your territory um
it's not like it's morally objectionable
but the purpose of
like living things of organic things
like
and even including your mind including
your thought
you should be trying to
de-territorialize yourself
i think that that that's perfect and i
like this example of the city
because what does a city do a city is
a territory right the street goes one
way
buildings go up um you have certain
places that you can go to
certain um places to eat et cetera
places you can
walk places you can't walk places you
walk you can walk places you can't walk
so it sets in a set of behaviors
so this is re-territorialization it
makes you
i'm going to use a big word here
converge to that place of power
so it makes you contract a certain habit
converge isn't the biggest word you
could use but yeah
okay sorry let's go on about let's go on
about the habit though the habit's
really
key here yeah so so delis will say that
you contract a habit because of
re-territorialization because you're
forced to walk a certain way
or should go um to use certain washrooms
or
to do etc you're supposed to do all of
this behavior you're contracting these
these passive habits
in order be because of the structure
because of the
as pill said the arborescent structure
so the structure of the tree
now how can we how can we
over or how can we yes how can we
overcode
this coded structure besides you know
just running into the street and getting
hit by a car
which is not the proposal here but
but yeah how do you how would you
overcode the
the habit well let's let's give some um
political examples i i think they're i
think these are fun
so we brought up the example of um
african-american americans in the 80s
and this idea of taking back the space
this
is exactly a d territorialization i
think i think
um uh de lis brings this up in actually
one of his lectures
um this idea of you know even just
expressing yourself within the street
taking over that's that that space
um overcoating the fact that you are now
on the sidewalk or in the middle of the
street where cars are supposed to be
driving
and you've taken all that space right
this is kind of showing the major
it's it's kind of trying to be it's
becoming and it's trying to
overcode or or become over the the major
and that's what protest is right because
you're entering the
street you take it over cars can no
longer drive but as a
as a rhizomatic entity even these police
protests you could say
is a is rhizomatic in that sense
absolutely disrupts
the code and the code is right cars
can't drive here anymore
right um i was also thinking of
a canadian example i think in 1986 the
indigenous population took over the
highway in quebec
um and canada brought in the military i
i believe
and here we have a great example because
you have a peep a minority that's
that's oppressed now they're taking to
the streets they're in the middle of a
highway
and what do you do on a highway you
speed right unless you're
um so they're they're taking over this
space they're over coding the specific
space
they're expressing themselves they are
right there a line of flight they are a
divergence
oh wait wait wait wait jargon oh jargon
whoops
sorry jargon alert okay just explain
line of flight
it's a perfect it's a great word for
this so let's let's go so
a line a line of flight here would now
be deterritorialization so it's an
actualized it's it's a it's an
expression
of breaking the structure breaking that
arborescence structure so here you have
an indigenous population trying to um
uh fight
let's go let's go to what actually line
of flight means
right because he uses the example of a
bowman
with an arrow this is what a line of
flight is so
right you notch your bow from whatever
position you have because no matter who
you are
you're in a territory um you know
a visible minority not a visible
minority you
are in the territory you shoot your bow
and this is what the line the word line
of flight comes from you shoot your bow
the arrow goes up and you're not gonna
you're not sure where it's gonna land
but it's your moral unction
as a living person as a living being
with you know
will to power you have to shoot your
arrow
just to see where it lands and he gets
he gets that concept from nietzsche
they both get it from nietzsche very
nichian throughout but then
you go find your arrow now you're stuck
in a new territory
so don't just stay there in your new
territory i mean it's it's
it's not like this is good or bad right
it's not like re-territorialization is
always good
and territorial as a territorializing is
always bad that's not at all what's
happening here but
the idea is as a nomad don't stay in any
place
too long because then you're not acting
out
your your in your intensities the
intensities that exist in you
as a living thinking person
i have a i have a better example there's
a
1970s pianist named messiah
and messian actually wanted to break
away from the
chord you know three chord chorus
structure and music and decided to mimic
bird sounds
and so he wanted to play specific bird
sounds so
what a perfect way what a perfect line
of flight
now you're gonna you're gonna create a
piece of music
that at the same time is rhizomatic
because it's
joining human creativity with
animal creativity we have two things
together
conjoined as one one flowing line of
flight
an assemblage here assembling
assemblaging
ah assembling an animal
line of flight and a human line of
flight together
man you keep bleeding these concepts so
perfectly because this is the body
without organs right
a body with organs like you could think
of your own body
it's a structure it has a certain amount
of
parts in it your heart your lungs your
pancreas your appendix
some of those organs are important
some you can't live without some you can
but there's even a hierarchy
of of organs in this sense so breaking
even down that hierarchy is the body
without organs it's just intense
on its way to something coming from
something
and it's not like oh i don't have a body
that's not at all
what what they're saying the idea is
instead of thinking
of your position in the world as part of
hierarchies
think of yourself as something on the
way to something else
you're a becoming not a being you're not
an identity
you're a becoming identity so you're
creating and then like
you're it's not like you're gonna finish
creating your identity and then just be
something
as soon as you get there then you should
be thinking like what what else can be
and this is i guess the political
dimension of delusion guitarii
which some people think that he's not
political
but the whole idea is just resist
because resistance has a value
in itself even if you don't accomplish
anything like the goal is not
we need revolution the goal is
make sure that you on your own are not
even on your own but just like as a
collective
or whatever part you are you're not just
a member of a class and you're not just
a member of a group you're always on
your way
to something and if you think of
yourself in this sense your life
becomes a work of art not a work of
you know fitting yourself into a system
or fitting yourself as an
organ into a whole into a totality a
state
that that was just beautifully well
worded no i went off
i went off a little bit i don't usually
like to be didactic
but you know what this is one of my
favorite philosophers for exactly this
reason it's like
no matter what you're doing you could be
doing it more creatively
if you're a scientist you could be doing
it better
yeah you could be you could be using
science
for life as opposed to life for science
um in a creative sense or science for
death if you're working for
[ __ ] halliburton or something like
that right
um yeah very very very interesting
um so there's he you know there's
great examples with music as well too um
the great french singer edith pf she
would sing normal you know verse chorus
verse
but she would sing a little off-tune and
the off-tune um
[Music]
just the thing just the action of of
singing off tune dillas loved her
loved her and he loved this idea that
okay you have someone that's
maintaining the same structure of songs
like verse chorus verse but
is overturning that structure just by
singing off
and and her songs are brilliant um
anyways okay so i was gonna try to keep
this is a micro dose so i was gonna try
to keep it
to about an hour um we were
we said we were going to talk about four
different delizes the dng delays
intellectual historian delays
metaphysician delivers aesthetics
um and we haven't really talked about
any of them specifically
but and we're not going to i don't think
we don't have enough time but in each
case when
like when he's reading a philosopher
he's not trying to repeat to you what
that philosopher said
just like baldly it's not information
transfer it's
it's here's this interesting concept
that we can get out of this philosopher
like the the the monad
or or the assemblage or whatever it is
um de luz as a metaphysician tries to do
this uh as the liz
tries to do this like let's just read a
movie and pretend that it's a berkshire
documentary or something but you know
what you know what we can still we can
still adhere to your four delusions by
taking an example from each let's do
that
here we go let's start off with the
monograph delis for a second with
something as easy as the concept so
de les believed that the history of
philosophy was about one thing
creation and he actually says this at
the end of
uh what is philosophy i'm pretty sure he
actually says that
in the first page of what his philosophy
oh yeah creators
creators of the world create so what is
what is the
what could can philosophers do but
create the concept
so exactly what what pills said so
you take something like his book on
spinoza which is one of my favorites
actually
um and this book is is about spinoza's
philosophy
but it hinges on a line of flight in it
called
expressionism how can one
express oneself infinitely
and this is also rhizomatic because
expression
is is infinite it's never ending
you have an infinite amount of
possibilities to express oneself and
either identity
behavior action right this is a great
way of overturning those passive habits
so this book focuses on expressivity
in what he calls the konatis which is a
spinoz spinosus term
for a will a striving um just like that
that idea of the arrow and shooting an
arrow like a line of flight
this is how we're supposed to look at a
mode of creation
creation as a form of expression so
there's a philosophical example and it's
also not just creation of i need to sit
down and write a book
right um just to summarize the rest of
what is philosophy
scientists can either you know be
creative
or not artists can be creative or
not but being creative at every
different moment
means a different thing and that's kind
of the the
crux the center of delizes all four
delusions
is that if you're stuck in one place
you're doing something
less than what you could be doing so
instead of
being instead of identity
in a very broad sense instead of things
you should think of things as
processes as things as as movements
on their way to something and this is
why the line of flight's so powerful
because you're on your way to something
instead of trying to establish what you
are establish
futures possibilities even if it's
useless
right this is so this is so important
because if you
you're reading the history of philosophy
everything's focused on
space and time and here and now and
things like movement
objects subject versus object which is
the subject which is the object
you know right and movement movement
overcomes all of this
movement is this flux right and within
this flux we have this
great capacity this great potential for
for creation which is why he ultimately
opts
a hundred percent for bergson's
understanding of time
and to a lesser extent nietzsche's
understanding of time versus
kant or hegel's sense of time which is a
fixed space
right he he says about kant um one of
the one of the most ingenious but also
maddening concepts is is um this idea of
taking time and making it clock time
making it internal
making time a kind of circle um he says
in the comic book
or being linear right because as soon as
you have a linearity
between cause and effect then you're
doing tree philosophy again you're doing
arborescent philosophy instead of
rhizome philosophy
rhizome philosophy at any moment has
like 20 directions and you have to
choose which ones to follow you have to
choose well
and intelligently not just doing things
for no reason
but you know taking taking your
intensity in that moment
into account in your expressivity
but you see you brought up something
really interesting and um
i want to talk about art for one second
because i was never an artist i know you
are
but i i came i be i became interested in
art because of de las
and his book the logic of sensation
which focuses on francis bacon
was my first real juncture into art
and the one thing that i like about this
is that you can really
see the creation in this so there's a
painting by
um princess bacon about um
pope pius vi i believe um and it's
and it's a pope's screaming and his half
of his face is melt
melting off we actually saw this yes in
person you and i
but yeah his face is melting off and uh
it's very gestural it's very
impressionistic
it's not like a true-to-life portrait
although it is based on a child life
portrait right
it is it is based on that but what he
does here is he
he does not define the figures of the
body
the body is actually blurred because
what is the body the body and organs etc
is back to again this concept of the
tree so he blurs the distinction
but what he does give you is the voice
the mouth is open so you can almost hear
the virtual
the virtual scream of this maddening
pope
you can see his jaw extended the
darkness
inside his mouth you can see this and
this is what for
fertilize is is art art as a line of
flight
is this this kind of raw
um creative potentiality that breaks
open the same kind of
blase art
yeah are without feeling kind of
you know giant balloon dogs and giant
lollipops or whatever the [ __ ] they're
doing now
but you know he he actually loved
pollock too because pollock created what
he called in
any space whatever the this free-flowing
yeah
pollock's art is very non-hierarchical
because it's just
a splatter all over the entire thing
right
um okay so wrapping up chris
i think that you and i have to do
another episode on this because
i only got through like two paragraphs
of my notes
i think no no but i think we okay so we
did the art we did the art de las
the the uh aesthetic de las we did the
the philosophy de las we did
yeah but create sort of is kind of the
center of each of these things right
so i would say so we're going to talk to
ian buchanan
um ian buchanan takes a little bit more
of a
a political stance i would say on the
liz um he talks a little bit more about
as well as one of our teachers who we
won't mention but
um a political stance to deliz because
one of the accusations against the liz
is not at all political or is that he's
anti-political right or something he
wants to do like
i don't know tree worshiping in a grove
or
like going to your hut in the woods or
some [ __ ] like heidegger but no
de luz the lizard and especially when
he's writing with katari he's very much
about
like wherever you're at i guess
here's here's my attempt at a summary
you should correct it if it's wrong
wherever you're at whatever you're doing
if you're a musician if you're an artist
if you're a political subject if you're
a minority if you're a reader if you're
a writer
you could be changing the very
definitions
of what you're doing through your work
so you shouldn't be something right
it's not about being something it's
about you said the word the virtual
and i i promised that we would try not
to be jargony but the virtual
sorry the virtual is this pl field it's
a field of possibility
um and you should be attentive to that
in
whatever way you are and and one of
their critiques of the way that we live
today is that it's so statist
that we can't really see possibilities
of action anymore
because so many of these machines you
know you can talk about media
schools ideological state apparatuses
might be a good
a good fit in here so many of the
machines that we have to
live inside of capitalism
or prevent that kind of
seeing above or below i think he says in
uh antiopes
the schizophrenic is capable of seeing
above and below
and that's why the schizophrenic is the
model for those two books because they
can see
past and they can see as a multiple not
as a singular
person but as a multiple person and
that's one of the another key concepts
multiplicity
never think in right which which you
know is in line with assemblages
but a multiplicity is this like you said
this
multiple expressions of of
non-actual of non-actualized
individuality
you you are endless possibilities
endless possibilities
and they mean this quite literally it's
not like some self-help [ __ ]
that says be whoever you want no it's
like
there are options here actually he calls
them larval selves there are little
larval
little larval cells inside you as these
these you know
burgeoning um blossoming um
potentials you know there ready to be
actualized
uh right so i apologize for this but i
think we gotta
start wrapping this up if you want
another episode on this i think we could
probably do four um
but i wanna i wanna keep the microdoses
to about an hour so
uh just in conclusion and i want to like
this conclusion can last for
five ten minutes but we're when we're
talking about delusion philosophy it's
not but truth
is not the center of it
it's more like possibility and creation
are the center of it we're not sure
just find out what is because
what is is what it is now it's static
but if you look at becoming
what things could be then your entire
interpretation of the world in the world
around you
is not going to look so static so he's
yeah he says this for every
every different type of discipline is
read better read new read creatively
make stuff yeah in the nietzsche book he
says that the powers of the false
outweigh the powers of the true and what
he means by that is
is exactly what you're saying that
sounds like nietzsche said something
pretty much in in exactly those lines
didn't he
i i think so yes so um
i kind of want to search it up because
it's a freaking great quote
well it goes in line with a lot of your
videos a lot of your a lot of your uh
videos on youtube are
are very much on on you know sketching
the surface of that
um it's a shame because i wanted to talk
about university and the metaphysics
of his philosophy but next time next
time
um but yes i i definitely think that
he this is a philosopher that is an
artist number one
and and is creating um a manifesto for
other philosophers
to not just be bureaucratic academics
historians working on you know basic
ideas but to be
free-flowing ex
experimenting and investigating
expressions of
ideas and and you see this with
everything they've done from
running on literature and philosophy and
poetry
um art everything politics everything
i think i remember the the quote that i
was thinking of nietzsche says uh
the the true or the true world
wait the false world was always the true
one
and the true one was only added by a lie
and obviously that's a commentary on
plato who believes that you know
everything else is representation except
the true world
but he said the false the world of
appearances is the one that's always
real and then trying to get out of that
real world to the
double plus real world you know getting
out of the cave
that's the mistake you should be looking
at the world as you're in it
and from your research in vitalism this
is extremely important because
when life is at its best when life is
living
it's struggling against its
conditions it's extant conditions to
create
conditions in which it could uh
be more than it is evolve
i i like that because um deliza's
favorite example
of this is his example of the tick and
he loves the idea of a tick because a
tick can just sit there
on a tall piece of grass you know
waiting for an animal to come just so it
can drop by
but all it's the only thing that it has
to express itself is it's
it's um olfactory senses so its sense of
smell
right it's got very poor vision
so it's just it's trying it's using this
to the most
it's using every kind of feature of
itself you know
all right well i guess just to summarize
like no matter what you're doing
be an artist at it i guess um
and it doesn't have to be to get to
somewhere it doesn't have to be
to accomplish something specific but
you're being more alive while you're
doing that
then when you're falling into line and
this is this is the big point especially
when delusions with guitar
is resist for the sake of resistance
because that's
that's more in line with life
can i can i just bring up one shot and
it's about it's about you unfortunately
oh god
i know you don't i i know you don't like
now you're gonna you're gonna collapse
my uh sense of uh distance here
from the object that i'm discussing
anyways um
i i saw your your recent um video last
night about how you make videos
and i found it very delisian actually
because even the term plastic pills when
you just start describing
the concept of pills and then the
concept of plasticity
plastic those two concepts create a
multiplicity like this is a perfect
example
of delisian philosophy it's
deterritorializing and territorializing
in the same word
exactly so you have this the plasticity
of
society the plastic-ness of of
mundane existence and then you have
pills which are
you know the kind of binary of the mind
in the body right the
pills you know you know conquering or
how did you say it you said
control but i would love control would
love it if you over interpreted this
because i think when i had made that
stuff i had never read deliz yet so
just over interpret it you can you can
publish a paper
on my on my larval genius but i didn't
even
know what i was doing but this but even
this evening's example
um uh and you and the funny thing is
what a great example and i'm going to
continue with this and you're not
cutting this out
because you used to paint uh pills as
well too
like you show in the video you painting
these pills
and you take this possibility it's
becoming increasingly uncomfortable
you take this possibility and you
actualize it into art
and not only does it have an intensity
meaning it's got this
divergent line of flight here it's got
this
multiple meaning of plastic and the pill
and now it's an artwork now it's now
it's an x density
so it's got the intensive which is the
the kind of pure um overcoating
and it's got the extensive which is
now the actualized line of flight
anyways i think
i could do you one better and it's what
we're doing now
what the channel is doing what the rest
of the podcast guys are doing
we are trying to de-territorialize
education
from being a university pursuit because
the university
yeah uh let's just let's just go no
let's just go mum
on that because the university is a
terrible place
but we're territorializing education by
doing this
instead of doing that and we're going to
go after
we're going to have to go back to doing
that presumably
soon but this is better
this agrees this is this is prime d
territorializing
of of a hierarchical structure a stupid
hierarchical structure and i think yeah
this is a
a much better virtualize or
what do we call it expression into the
virtual
of making education
free and online you were about to say
great again weren't you
what's that i said you're about to say
make education great again weren't you
those were i'm joking those words never
crossed my mind no i didn't i'm just
kidding i'm kidding more like
more like make it free again yeah that's
good
so um moral of the story keep moving
and keep creating i think i'll close it
down on that thank you very much chris
um if you want more of this
comment otherwise we won't do it but you
know what we might do it anyways because
we've got a lot more to go through if
we're going to do an introduction to
duluth anyway our next episode
will be with esteemed
top five worldwide researcher on delu's
ian buchanan
i think we're gonna probably like let's
try to not talk too much during that
i think i mean ian's a chatty guy he'll
probably have a lot to say anyway
but i think so that'll be mostly an
interview style rather than a
conversation
if i if i get my way so uh stay tuned
for that
it's gonna be awesome it's gonna be
probably the best content
i've ever produced just because we have
an academic celebrity
so and thanks for having me on
the podcast again oh you're gonna be
back this was a micro dose but we're
gonna go
do an overdose we gotta keep on theme
with the pills right
all right chris great to have you uh
thank you turn your ac
back on because i'm freaking dying in
here so
me too peace everyone